valerie has a brand new agent and she's
well
really really fast
she's a sprinting walling stunning hand
lasering new duelist and the verdict's
still out about whether or not she's
gonna see any competitive play that's
right neon is here we've got a brand new
act new map changes new gun changes sexy
new skins and the valor and champions
tour is right around the corner
oh
and the aries is uh
well it's broken in half
i'm back on camera and i want you guys
to know that just because my job has
kept me mostly off camera lately i've
dearly missed
you guys calling me stoned in the
comments section so make sure you like
subscribe and scroll down
and roast me like you always do now the
holidays may have just ended but this
past tuesday we all teleported to our
own personal valorant christmas land we
have a brand new act a new battle pass
map changes to both breeze and bind they
finally nerfed the specter and yes a new
agent
neon
neon is a fast fun and ferocious new
duelist that boasts some of the most
unique abilities we've seen in ballarat
thus far in addition to maybe the best
theme song in esports history
yeah that [ __ ] bangs her first and
signature ability is a sprint yeah
she's fast that's her thing she can also
combo her sprint with a slide and yes it
does really look like a call of duty
slide cancel then her first supporting
ability is a stun grenade it bounces
once stuns two places and leaves enemies
paralyzed much like breeches stun this
thing's got the potential for some
absolutely insane lineups her last
regular ability i personally think might
be her best she's got this double wall
the wall anchors to wherever you shoot
it so you can shoot it into the back
wall of the site splitting the site in
half and allowing your team to walk out
and weave in and out of it and last
we've got our all which is this wild
finger laser hand cannon
thing when neon was first announced neon
slide you know that one that i said
looks like a call of duty slide well it
was supposed to reset every single time
you got a kill while you were in your
ultimate
riot has since decided that that might
have been a little too good so they've
taken it away you're gonna be able to
chain off a lot of kills with this
ultimate and i promise you whether neon
is competitively viable or not
we are going to see some pretty sick alt
clips
wait this is crazy
you can't um oh you can you can slide
with this too
bro i want to play this character oh my
gosh
that's so cool this is actually gonna
like
like you know how like jet highlights
are exciting to watch i feel like neon
highlights are gonna be exciting to
watch too now before i get into the
whole analysis of whether or not neon is
competitively viable blah blah blah let
me just say this
we can all agree
she's coolest
it's pretty clear to me that if you're
not a sweaty tryhard or a pro player
this agent is super creative and she's
going to be really fun to mess around
with in ranked that said on this channel
we don't have fun on this channel we
sweat
just ask dimitri don't lose these
dimitri
oh no there's another one behind you
you're just so much
better
the first thing that comes to mind when
i look at her kit is that she's going to
be a terror on rotation she's going to
be able to get from sight to sight in
seconds
and that makes her a nightmare when
she's on defense her speed also makes
her uniquely good with a shotgun much
like rey's as average jonas showed off
for us on twitter
second her wall is just clearly pushed
this thing can split sites in half with
ease and is going to give your team a
ton to maneuver around when you're
trying to hit a sight on attack and with
agents like viper already being
essential for splitting sites on maps
like breeze
clearly teams want this kind of effect
now for me a huge signifier of her
competitive viability is going to be how
well her abilities work together i can
see a world where she walls the site
concusses the left side then slides out
the right side and entries and if that's
legitimately good at the highest level
maybe she can hang
i'm in a simulation right now bro
oh remaining okay
i'm out of here okay this is a trailer
damn
or if she's combo with agents like
breech who can flash ahead for her to
take advantage of her gap closing this
is something that asuna actually
suggested on stream yeah so i mean neon
does have a place if you don't want to
jet to dash and you want a neon to run
so
there are certain like
plays you could probably do with neon
where jet just can't like reach in time
um
if you really spend the time i think it
could be yeah
with that said there are those that are
simply
not believers and their thoughts are
probably best encapsulated by what tarik
said on stream i don't think she's gonna
be uh that sick but i don't know okay
let's just say hypothetically
hypothetically you got your the team's
like yo yo neon we need you to send it
up short a uh what do you got for us i'm
like i got you guys
that's it i'm in there like that that's
all i got really that's really literally
it the slide in my opinion needs to be
one second longer like it's so short
i barely can move man make me like slide
a little longer dude like i'm out of
here
i feel like i'm gonna be dead sliding in
all seriousness i do share some of that
same hesitation that taric has about her
kid that said there is a precedent set
by characters like chamber jet and reyes
that gap closers or quick escapes are
effective at the highest level but it's
really hard for me to believe that
you're going to see pro players
sliding around corners to peak each
other and not just dying instantly so
with her wall her stun and her ability
to rotate so quickly
maybe her competitive viability comes
down to how good that ultimate actually
is if you're gonna be able to mow down
the enemy team every four or five rounds
with a laser beam then
maybe she's worth it i don't know i'm
trying a thing they're going to be
coming for me
no way dude oh my god oh my god dude one
of our in-house writers and reporters
niall mccrosson spoke to valerian caster
hypoch the other day about whether he
thinks neon will see any pro play okay
first impressions of neon yes gonna be
viable i don't think it's uh it's a jet
replacement but i definitely think
there's gonna be you know an argument
for players that you know maybe play
rainer as kind of like that secondary
duelist but not necessarily
you know full-on focus as as entry um i
definitely think with like an initiator
heavy
composition there's going to be an
argument uh
to to play neon in certain scenarios but
yeah i don't think at the minute you
could you could say that it's a jet
replacement yet it's still just
too serviceable in in
you know the vast majority of
um situations only time will tell if
we'll ever see her in pro play but
whether she's for tens or just those
ranked demons on ladder i'm pretty
stoked she's in the game because much
like anyone who's ever even looked at a
vowel server i've seen my fair share of
criticism of jet lately and while i
obviously understand how push jet is she
also happens to be by far the most
exciting character to both play and
watch so the fact that riot is trying to
create more fast unique duelists rather
than just plodding along with more
smokes and sticky repetitive utility is
great as far as i'm concerned in my
opinion the game is much better when
people are popping off on jet rather
than just trying to simulate a cs go
game in a game that is well
not
counter-strike now with all that in mind
we spoke to streamer ethos the other day
and he had a pretty unique take he said
that while neon is a movement based
character
you should be considering her closer to
reyes than jay
she's much more like rey's than she is
jet in terms of shared movement needs to
be more calculated uh to set it up her
util is more for zoning
than for you know anything else um but i
will say that she does have more space
making ability uh than the other
traditional duelists and
can kind of rival jet on that on that
standpoint so if you for example take
out your jet for a chamber
for the op pressure
on defense and then you're now lacking
the space making uh capability neon
might be able to help with that
but
overall like neon can't be made as like
a huge comparison in jet now while neon
is the
talk of the virtual town
the new act has brought us a ton of
other changes that do have significant
competitive impact to start they've made
meaningful changes to two maps bind
and breeze on bind they've changed and
shortened the box on a short in order to
remove the one-way smoke spot that was
just
a little too good for the defenders they
also added a ledge to help that first
peak from market to a short and then on
breeze they've made actually pretty
significant changes to both sites on a
site they've really tightened the choke
point to get out onto site from cave and
also replace the triple box backsight
with a large metal box obviously both
changes will help the ct side players
hold the sight that said given that you
already needed viper to get out of cave
in the first place and my rank teammates
refused to pick viper hombres
we'll see how this goes on b site they
made another couple changes that will
help the defending side hold the site
adding a box to the pillar mid-site you
can hide behind and creating a wall at
the back of the site to help with some
added cover in addition to the changes
they've made to these two maps they've
also made a bunch of changes to the guns
many of us are buying on our half buys
the spectre the aries the guardian and
the bulldog have all been changed to
start after months of half by supremacy
the spectre
has been nerfed the bullet spray will
now start to get worse quicker because
riot says quote it was over performing
in long range engagements and was too
powerful even within its intended close
range and mobile scenarios end quote
which checks out since it seemed to be
by far the most popular gun that players
at valerant champions bought when they
were trying to save with this change and
buffs to the guardian aries and bulldog
hopefully we'll see a wider diversity of
half by guns that said in the early
going it seems like the aries is
absolutely broken in half and has just
replaced the spectre as the gun you have
to buy on your half by rounds
after winning pistol or if you're trying
to save this [ __ ] is broken loud and
extremely annoying it needs to be fixed
asap
oh my god
thank you guys one more
wait this gun is insane
wait
what
oh my god wait
[Music]
dude dude i can't see anything with this
gun out i can't see a single thing
like
come on okay now before i leave you you
know we gotta talk about them the skins
as with all new acts there is a brand
new battle pass now these red techie
skins they look awful to me but these
multicolored joints actually look really
sick for battle pass skins that said
personally i'm still waiting for prison
for
please please ryan we also got what
we're referring to in-house here at the
square esports is the buffed recon set
it's called protocol for my money this
set is absolutely sick and that's a lot
of money because
it's gonna cost you life savings to buy
it the inspect and reload animations are
some of the sickest in the game and this
whole robot theme goes really hard
there's still something really awesome
about these militaristic skin sets in a
game that's otherwise very colorful and
cartoony so there you go we got a new
year we got a new act we got a new
character i'm addicted to ranked again
you guys you scroll down hit me up in
the comments and let me know how good
you think neon is are we gonna see
sentinels and ascend and gambit playing
her at the next vct event
let me know
and has just
replaced the spectre as the gun
like
come on
like come on
like come on
like
come on
probably an option there